we're now closer than my friends and
family we've seen each other so much in
the last three weeks for the past three
weeks we we went to Brazil means St like
this Jesus really yeah with all the
traffic the two e is outrageous
outrageous no it's it's it's literally
another level just you can't describe it
it's wild it was probably because of
ComiCon I've been there a lot it's it's
it's crazy all right enough for
about bra let's
nightm so I like throwing a curveball at
the beginning you already know this I
don't think I asked you this so um this
is for the both of you um if someone has
never seen anything you've done before
what is the first thing you'd like them
watching and why holy crap I know I
answered this
question I suppose banshees just cuz it
seemed to hit you know a lot of people
seem to like it I guess so kind good I
guess I'd pick that one or look I did a
job with Michael man where I played a
jockey and I was with Nick no te I love
that I love that show that every actor
was incredible it was the camera
department is incredible loved it yeah
thanks um I already answered this
question dud wait what did iic Black
Mirror or dud no I don't think you
actually you I asked you what you your
dad would watch what you should watch
from your dad you might have said Lodge
49 like talked about it right I'd say
I'd say DED cuz I'd say that's closest
to like my
heart I'm going to watch it so don't
fall
asleep no it was good um just don't
watch it in the traffic in Brazil anyway
so um one of the things about horror
movies is they can really impact the way
you are in real life for example when I
saw Poltergeist as a kid I refused to
look under my bed because it it hit me
so I'm curious what films did you
possibly see at a young age that
actually impact you in real life do you
remember there was a movie about um it
was called small sacrifices for ARA
faucet she played a real life killer
Diane DS who murdered I know the whole
movie like practically she murdered her
kids and one of the kids she murdered
three of her kids because this boyfriend
didn't want to be a father and she's a
real woman and firef player and one of
the kids survived in real life and
testified like yeah my mom shot us and
like that totally stayed with me that
movie cuz I was very young when I watch
it and like there's a song in it that
like Diane DS played in the car when she
was shooting the kids and yeah sounds
like a laugher I mean I wasn't scared my
mother was going to shoot me but I was
like do you know that a woman could kill
her children like they just you know
like Humanity oh 100% so that and that I
remember that was scary yeah Sleeping
with the Enemy was another one that was
kind of scary yeah Julia
Roberts see these movies back in the '
80s 90s that's what I feel like night
swim is like good
[Laughter]
burger good burger was a film they're
making a good burger too actually it's
out out it is not scary it is it is so
bad it's good I gu it's more of a comedy
it's a comedy it's it used to be it's
it's uh it's a ridiculous moment well
how did it scare you it it wasn't scary
great a boto was putting um it was
poisoned by uh they poison the
sauce I remember I was sick from home
and there was Direct TV and I like
bought good burger and I was nine it's
the dumbest movie you've ever seen um
but I loved it when I was like 9 years
old it was perfect for me cute so one of
the things about night swim is it
reminds me why I will not go in the
ocean or in a pool because you never
know what's down there let's let's be
honest movies have corrupted me um so
talk a little bit though what day of the
this I don't know how I connected to
this but what day of the shoot were you
like no more water day
one I still love swimming so I can't say
that it affected me at all I love water
I love being in the pool um so but um
filming in water it's totally different
than being in water so I think if I was
to film in water again I would ask that
we do that at the beginning of the shoot
as oppos to the end of the
Sho yeah
um it was about day three uh for me of
the water stuff where I was like I'm
good well I got sick and so I was like I
don't The Producers were awesome and
warmed the water up and and it was 98°
it was balmy wonder I felt it was
unhygienic at that
temperature quite frankly and it was uh
it was a rough go for me for the rest of
the shoot but it was it was yeah I'd say
day three I asked this of uh of everyone
I speak to when they're involved in like
a scary movie or a horror movie what do
you think it is about the genre that
people love watching them and love being
scared yeah we were talking about this
earlier my theory is it's just like you
feel alive so like any extreme emotion
makes you feel alive so like roller
coaster rides things like that or
Adrenaline Junkies people who love doing
like crazy kind of things it's that
similar thing of of that and then I
suppose it's probably a community too
like they Pro you know I imagine a lot
of horror people like talk about
different horor things and criticize and
you like different horor things it's
probably a community that's feels good
to be a part of people like being part
of a group and I I for me I think that
the psychological element is like this
thing can't hurt me it can't physically
do harm to me but I can experience this
terrifying uh you know Supernatural
element of whatever it is that I'm
watching for that contained amount of
time and then go back to my the safety
of my home that part of it I think is
the what makes the best horror films
like I I'm not a big fan of like slasher
movies that just slash and like you know
it could happen to anybody that's not I
don't love them but when they're you
know like The Shining and all these
great horror movies reference you know
it get referenced to nauseum they're
great because there's like a there's an
existential crisis happening somewhere
and it's always set against a great
backdrop that usually has to deal with
some kind of Supernatural element even
if it's in someone's head or if it's
their swimming pool or if it's their
haunted house
things that you know we don't
necessarily experience in everyday life
that's fun to just get a snippet of and
you know get that like Carrie said the
little jolt I have an individual
question for you uh I am very excited
for skeleton key because it's Skeleton
Crew yes would I say wrong don't worry
at all yeah me because it's John Watts
uh he's such a talented director and I'm
just could you talk a little bit about
uh the the role and what you're excited
for people to see oh gosh i' be
strangled if I talk about the role don't
W you know I will be um what I'm excited
to see what am I excited for people to
see um oh Jesus I feel like I'm walking
a tight rope you know what these people
are like I know um the four leads are so
great their four leads are so great and
they're very young and they're really
great and they're adorable to be around
um so that would be the first thing and
also it's for an age group that's a
really cute age group of children it
it'll appeal to an age group of children
I think that'll be really nice that I
I'm not sure has been targeted before
sure uh thank you so much for your time
I hope it's a huge hit for you guys and
I'm not talking to you again for the
rest of the
year